so far we've seen persona 5 DLC costumes
based off the main line personas and
shin megami tensei if this third week of
stylish threads goes beyond school
uniforms and features the fashions of
persona 4 dancing all night and shin
megami tensei 4 with more throwback
battle music cycling through this
gameplay footage will show these new dlc
outfits plus some handy personas from
persona 4 arena Ultimax
and free swimsuits let's go
[Music]
[Music]
from you joke's on you
[Music]
can't beat that loser on your knees
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
alright you got lucky
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now let's continue
[Music]
[Music]
next you'll withdraw this persona this
is your power stiff persona a fee is
required
this is your power is this what you want
you'll withdraw this persona this is
your power
[Music]
from you joke's on you so what are your
favorite persona duds - Seymour persona
5 DLCs give us a like and subscribe to
our YouTube channel thanks for watching